as the meetings in phnom penh drew to a
close cambodia's foreign minister who's
chair of the association of southeast
asian nations acknowledged the
difficulties that lay ahead we know that
every year
we have our set of challenges to address
but i have to say that never before
not like this year have we been
confronted with so many perils at the
same time
tensions over the war in ukraine and u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taiwan have overshadowed events here
the divide between the u.s and its
allies on one hand and china and russia
on the other appears to have deepened
china and russia's top diplomats walked
out of the east asia summit when the
japanese foreign minister was speaking
reportedly in protest against japan's
criticism of beijing's military
exercises around taiwan
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
said there was no justification for
china's actions these provocative
actions
are a significant escalation
we've seen how beijing has attempted to
change the status quo in taiwan for some
time
for example
more than doubling the number of
aircraft flown over the center line
that separates china and taiwan over the
past two years
pursuing economic work political
interference and cyber attacks
against taiwan
now
they've taken dangerous acts to a new
level
the united states is conveyed
to the prc
consistently
and repeatedly
that we do not seek
and will not provoke a crisis
it's unlikely china will back down its
foreign minister has criticized the u.s
and defended beijing's actions
pelosi's visits has seriously impacted
china's sovereignty
seriously interfered in our
international affairs violated the
promise u.s had made with china and
seriously harmed the taiwan straits
relations
so it is only natural the chinese side
must show our strong opposition
asean foreign ministers had warned on
thursday the risk of miscalculations in
the taiwan strait could lead to
confrontation among major powers
in cambodia there's been no signs that
the meeting of the last two days have
helped ease tensions florence louis al
jazeera phnom penh